this video is hexokinase in 2d I also
have a 3d version that's meant to be
viewed with Google cardboard or a VR
headset you can grab a cardboard for
about 15 bucks and enjoy a really cool
3d experience or continue on with this
video and watch my 2d version if you
haven't watched what does a protein
really look like do that first so you
understand what you're seeing here if
you're ready let's begin
carbohydrates are an important source of
energy some tissues like the brain and
kidneys exclusively use glucose for
energy and glucose can produce energy
even in the absence of oxygen like when
your muscles are working overtime the
protein spinning around here is
hexokinase the first enzyme involved in
carbohydrate metabolism in most living
cells hexyl kinase is an enzyme so it
catalyzes a chemical reaction and the
kinase part of the name means it adds a
phosphate to something this is the
overall reaction shown in a way that
you're probably used to seeing it
glucose reacts with ATP and a phosphate
group replaces the hydrogen on one of
the O h groups now let's view these
molecules in a more biochemical way
here's glucose shown as sticks which is
a common way to look at molecules bound
to proteins I've colored carbon white
and the oxygen atoms are in there CPK
red we can also look at a side view of
this molecule and see that it sits in a
chair conformation those chair diagrams
you might have had to draw for ochem
class are relevant now let's compare
this to the product of the reaction
glucose 6-phosphate which all called g6p
we have a new CPK color to introduce
here phosphorus atoms are orange our
other substrate is ATP look at how huge
this molecule is
there's the adenosine ring the sugar and
the triphosphate group it looks a whole
lot smaller when we abbreviate it as
three letters ADP is the other product
of the reaction notice the terminal
phosphate from ATP has been cleaved off
phosphate groups are negatively charged
in the body and the charges would be
drawn on these oxygen atoms
glucose is a neutral molecule and passes
from the bloodstream into the cell
easily once the phosphate is on there
the charge prevents it from leaving the
cell so it stays inside to provide
energy for cellular processes now let's
look at hexokinase there are four
isoforms of this enzyme isoforms our
enzymes that perform the same reaction
but have different though often similar
amino acid sequences first let's look at
hexokinase four also called glucokinase
this form is predominantly found in the
liver and when glucose levels are high
it facilitates storage of glucose as
long chains of glycogen for later use
when the enzyme is unbound it exists in
this open form but once a molecule of
glucose binds the enzyme clamped shut
around it this change in conformation is
called induced fit let's check that out
one more time
when unbound glucokinase is wide open
glucose binds and the protein changes
shape and closes down around it so cool
in mammals hexokinase isozymes 1 2 & 3
are twice as large as glucokinase let's
take a look at hexokinase 1 as our
example the amino acid sequence and
structure of each half is very similar
so scientists hypothesized that this is
because the gene for the protein was
doubled up in the genome during
evolution the ultimate protein product
resulted from fusion of the two genes
the halves of the protein are linked
covalently by this alpha helix what's
super neat about this enzyme is that
only one half actually performs the
reaction the c-terminal unit which i've
colored cyan performs catalysis and the
yellow end terminal piece binds the
product of the reaction g6p binding g6p
changes the shape of the c-terminal unit
and inhibits enzyme activity if there's
a lot of g6p there's no reason for the
enzyme to
make more inhibition of an enzyme by a
product of the same pathway is called
feedback inhibition and since the
inhibition occurs by binding the
inhibitor outside of the active site
it's also called allosteric inhibition
there is an amazing crystal structure of
glucokinase that I'm going to show you
the enzyme has basically been caught in
the act of catalysis first let's review
the structure of ATP the phosphates are
linked together by oxygen atoms but in
this molecule a NP the last phosphorus
atom is linked through a nitrogen atom
this is an important molecule in
studying enzymes because this last
phosphate cannot be broken off
structurally it's similar enough to ATP
that will bind in its place but it
cannot do the reaction let's look at the
active site of glucokinase now and see
where the chemical reaction magic
happens in this crystal structure
there's a molecule of glucose bound the
O h groups on glucose are interacting
with nearby amino acid residues in
hydrogen bonds I've shown the important
active site residues as green sticks and
the hydrogen bonds as yellow dashes now
here's a NP it's also making hydrogen
bonds to nearby amino acids but here
it's making a bond to a red sphere that
red sphere is a water molecule and the
water makes hydrogen bonds with a
backbone of the enzyme we call this a
water mediated hydrogen bond you see a
protein crystal is not a hard crystal
it's a flexible crystal that forms with
lots of water molecules trapped inside
if it dried out completely it would lose
its shape since water is abundant in the
human body
we need to mimic that environment and
protein crystals are therefore quite
hydrated I want to point out one
interaction here in a little more detail
this is an interaction between a
phosphate oxygen and a lysine this is
likely an ionic bond
the phosphate has negative charge at
biological pH and lysine is one of the
basic amino acid residues it gains a
proton at biological pH and becomes
positively charged so it's important to
remember rules for ionization when
looking at crystal structures but wait a
second there's also this gray sphere
that's a magnesium ion hexokinase
requires that ATP bind with magnesium to
perform the reaction magnesium is an
enzyme helper and that's why it's
important to have in your diet the metal
has a two plus charge and this interacts
with the negative charges on the
phosphate oxygens which helps it bond to
glucose look how close glucose is oxygen
atom is to the phosphate it's positioned
perfectly to react if this were ATP so
neat now check out this aspartate
residue over here this is an acidic
amino acid and is an anion at biological
pH this is the amino acid residue that
accepts the proton off of glucose which
allows it to use those electrons that
are left behind to bond to the phosphate
group I want to show you one more way
that you might see the active site of
this protein rendered sometimes for
clarity only the active site residues
are shown then none of the rest of the
protein gets in the way and we can
clearly see the most important amino
acids thanks for sticking around to the
end and diving into an active site with
me I'm amazed every time I learn about
an enzyme and it's so powerful that I'm
able to look at a crystal structure
myself and prove wine enzyme can do the
amazing chemistry that it does there are
links in the video description for
modeling software and to these crystal
structures go to the PDB and look at
some proteins